So far the machines we've made
in our reductions ie the ends,
have been relatively uncomplicated.
They all either accepted every string or
they accepted no strings.
Unfortunately, reductions
can't always be done that way.
Since the machine that always loops and
the machine that always accepts.
Might both be in or might not be
in the language we're reducing to.
In these cases,
we need N to pay attention to its input.
Here's an example were
we will need to do this.
The language of descriptions
of Turing machines,
where the Turing machine
accepts exactly one string.
It doesn't make much
of a difference which
undecidable language we reduce from.
So this time,
we'll reduce from the halting problem
to this single acceptance language.
Again, there are many
possible reductions.
I like this one.
We run the input machine
M on the empty string.
If M loops, then so will N.
We don't accept one string,
we accept none.
On the other hand,
if M does halt on the empty string,
then we make N act like
a machine in this language, S.
We'll have it just accept the empty
string, my favorite string.
This works because if M
loops on the empty string
than N will loop on every input and
hence accept nothing.
On the other hand,
if M does halt on the empty string,
then N will accept exactly one string,
the empty string.
Once again, in one case,
the language of N is the empty set.
In the other case,
the language of N is the empty string.
A decider for
the language S can tell the difference.
And therefore, would be able to decide
if M halted on the empty string or not.
Since this is impossible, a decider for
this single acceptance
language cannot exist.